CLIFF: So gathering in a room
full of people, many of whom
are strangers,
it's something that
feels uncomfortable
to a lot of us.
Now Susan RoAne is here to
help fix that challenge.
She's here to speak about
her landmark book-- currently
celebrating its 25th
year of publication--
"How to Work a Room."
It's sold over 1.2 million
copies in over 13 countries.
And even though much of
our daily communication
involves technology, whether
it's in the workplace
or at a wedding or
at a fundraiser,
we still need this bit of
face to face interaction.
And that's what
Susan brings along.
Now, the book has gotten a wide
variety of press and acclaim,
so she's shared information
about the book in various news
outlets.
It's gotten some really
great endorsements
from people such as Guy
Kawasaki and Daniel Pink.
And Susan is a
professional speaker.
And her clients range throughout
the industry, anywhere
from Coca Cola and
United Healthcare
to the United States
Air Force, some
of the folks down
at Apple or Oracle,
or on her current favorite,
which is Hershey's Chocolate.
Now, on a personal
note, Susan did graduate
from the University of Illinois,
as I did and many of us
here in the audience.
So it's always great to bring
another bit of the Illini love
home here to Mountain View.
And so without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming back to Authors
at Google, the keynote speaker,
bestselling author, and the
mingling maven, Susan RoAne.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SUSAN ROANE: Well,
you heard Cliff
say that I've been written
up in a lot of places.
And this book is celebrating
its silver anniversary.
Someone asked me, why
would you write it again?
This is the fourth iteration.
And I said the last issue
that came out was 2007.
I wrote it in 2006.
And it's not that
people have changed.
In fact, people still
want to be comfortable.
They want to have conversations.
We want to have fun.
We want to feel appreciated.
We want to feel listened to.
We want to feel that
we're important.
But what's changed
is technology.
When I first wrote "How to
Work a Room." the research
at Stanford's research clinic
by Doctor Phillip Zimbardo,
he found that 80% of American
adults self-identify as shy.
That's a huge portion.
By the time the third
iteration came out
in 2000, that jumped to 93%.
They asked Doctor Zimbardo, what
do you attribute that big jump?
That's huge.
13% more people are
self-identifying as shy.
And he said one
word-- "Technology."
Can you imagine now, 14 years
later, how we're communicating?
How much technology
has changed us?
But really, we're the same.
It's just some of our
behaviors have changed.
I also rewrote it because
some of the things
no longer applied.
There are some terms
that would make no sense.
And there were things
I needed to add in.
So there's a brand new chapter
called "New Rooms to Work."
And even though I had written
about LinkedIn and Facebook,
we now have this new
room called Twitter.
And then there's Instagram,
and then there's Google+.
So I had to include
that in the book.
And by the way, if anyone
wants to give me an additional
tutorial on Google+,
see me after the class.
But I had to do that.
Also, I'm originally
from Chicago,
which is why I went to Illinois.
And I had to delete things
of people who were dead
and-- if you'll forgive me--
people who were dead to me.
I took them out of the book.
And I added in a chapter
called-- because I,
again it's with the puns--
a whole chapter called
"Roominations," but I
spelled it R-O-O-M--
little tidbits to get you
through any event in any room.
But writing a book
is interesting.
By the way, writing
a book doesn't
mean you dress up like this.
It's, for me, on a
dining room table
open twice the size with
the congratulatory chocolate
at my left hand.
That's how that worked.
And I've been asked
how I write my books.
What program do you use?
Here's the program--
hand, number two pencil
with good erasers,
and I didn't even
write on the back on
yellow legal paper,
because that would be a
waste to this former teacher.
I write my books on
the back of used paper.
They call it recycling.
And someone once said,
well, that's cheap of you.
But I really thought it
was very forward thinking.
It doesn't matter
how we write a book,
it matters that we write
a book, and that we just
pick up whatever tool we use.
"How to Work a Room" first
came out 25 years ago.
I'm a former school teacher
in San Francisco and Chicago.
I was so excited,
because the "Wall Street
Journal" reviewed my book.
I was excited until
I read what it said.
So let me quote.
I found out later
this review was
written by actually one of
my heroes, David Brooks, who
now writes for the
New York Times.
He thought he was
being satirical.
I didn't know that.
It broke my heart.
Here's what he wrote.
"At last, the perfect how-to
book for shallow people."
I was really upset.
And then a gentleman who worked
for the Chamber of Commerce
in San Francisco said
to me, you know nothing
about marketing, Susan.
I don't?
He said, shallow
people, don't you
know that's a market of 40 to 50
million potential book buyers?
And by the way,
because all of you
are going to get your
Google special price book,
I know that the people who
bought "How to Work a Room"
aren't shallow.
Based on the work of Doctor
Bernardo Carducci and Doctor
Zimbardo, who
specialize in shyness,
people bought the book
because we are shy.
And it doesn't mean we're shy
at work when we know people
and see them every day.
We might be shy if we're
invited to a party.
I went to a wedding two
weeks ago in San Francisco,
and I only knew the
bride and the groom.
The were busy.
They didn't have
time to talk to me.
I had to make sure that
I introduced myself
to people, talked
to them, et cetera.
Because that's on me.
Though there was,
at one point, I
thought to myself,
oh my goodness.
What did I write on page 230?
It might be helpful.
But working a room is work.
And you heard that I am
a professional speaker.
I speak about this all the time.
I actually just
came from Hollywood
where I spoke about how to
work a room for a leadership
conference for a global company.
But right before my
speech, I went over
to Universal City Walk,
because I actually
wanted to the see King Kong
hanging from the rafters.
And I took a picture of it.
But as I got off the
little shuttle bus,
I saw a man and a
woman walking this way.
I was walking into
the City Walk.
Strangers next to me, and
the guy looked familiar.
And I did a double take.
And then I said to these
guys that I didn't know,
that looks like
Sugar Ray Leonard.
The guy said to
me, well, that is.
And in a split second, I
had to make a decision.
Was I going to
continue, or was I
going to go over and
meet Sugar Ray Leonard?
And I thought, this is a once
in a lifetime opportunity.
Have any of you had that
happen, where you see someone
and you know if you
don't say anything,
you'll never have
another opportunity?
I decided to take it.
Because guess what?
How do I not if I
wrote this book?
Who should listen to me?
So I went over and
I stood and waited
while a gentleman who was a
big fight fan talked to him.
And then I stood in the
corner, and here's what he did.
The celebrity, this man
of great acclaim, saw me,
and he walked over to me,
big smile on his face.
I knew he was the
champ, because guess
what it said on his
t-shirt-- "champ."
I'm thinking I'm going to
get one that says "author,"
and on the back say
"professional speaker."
I thought it was
good advertising.
Smile on his face,
and I got so giddy.
I said to him, I'm so excited.
Could you please
make my heart flutter
and let me take
a picture of you?
And Sugar Ray Leonard said no,
with a big smile, and said,
we have to take a
picture together.
Be still my heart.
With a smile on his face,
so friendly, so welcoming.
You know, I think when you're
a big enough celebrity,
you know how to behave.
And I wish he could give
lessons to the rest of them that
end up on TMZ.
By the way, I took
that tour the next day.
But Sugar Ray Leonard did this.
And as I was backing away
saying oh thank you so much,
I'm so excited, I
did say to him--
and got permission-- I said I'm
here to speak to a conference.
And I said, I wrote "How to
Work a Room"-- shameless plug,
got that in to the champ.
And I said, would
it be OK with you
if I tell the story how we met?
And he said, absolutely.
And I was beginning to
walk away because I didn't
want to hog his time--
which, by the way,
when you meet someone
who is of that celebrity,
whether it's Larry
or Sergei or whoever,
you don't want to
hog their time.
But you want to make
sure you talk to them.
He said, wait a minute.
Let's see if the
pictures turned out.
How nice.
How thoughtful.
How kind.
And they did.
Of course, went
right up on Facebook.
Tweeted about it.
Found there were a
whole lot of fight fans
that retweeted my tweet.
But what I knew is he
was there because he
was doing a fundraiser
to fight diabetes.
And for me, I wanted to tweet
that because my mom had that
as well.
So really, that's the story.
But that's not the
reason I'm telling you.
A couple of years
ago, I was having
dinner with a friend in Novato,
and a gentleman was at the bar.
We had forgotten to have
the waitress take a picture.
By the way, now that we all
have cameras on our phones,
we all want to take pictures.
So I saw this
gentleman at the bar.
There were only two of them.
It was a rainy night in Marin.
And I said to my
friend, oh, I think
we can ask this gentleman
to take our picture.
He had a big welcoming smile.
I went over with
my camera and said,
would you please take a
picture of my friend and me?
And he started to laugh.
Of course.
He took the picture.
We walked out.
We are in the lobby,
and my friend said,
I think that was Chris
Robinson from Black Crow.
You mean I just asked Chris--?
No wonder he was laughing.
He thought I was saying, can
I take a picture with you?
But I said, I think
I insulted him.
I must go back and
apologize to Chris Robinson
and ask for a picture.
And my friend said
to me, don't do that.
You don't need to
talk to him again.
Here's my lesson.
Don't ever listen to
someone who tells you
what to do that doesn't have
your interest, your values,
your confidence, and your
desire to do something,
because they won't
be less comfortable.
But you'll walk away feeling,
gosh, I should have done that.
Have any of you done that,
where someone said to you,
don't do something?
You listen to them,
and you though,
oh my goodness, that's the best.
I'm never doing that again.
I learned my lesson.
And I wasn't going to
let that happen again
with Sugar Ray Leonard.
But working a room is work.
In the book, I talk
about the road blocks
besides the shyness,
the remedies,
and we talk about the
strategies to make conversation.
I'm the original
small talk fan I
know there are a lot of people
that say, I'm really important.
I can't waste my
time on small talk.
Let's say you're at an event.
You're at a conference.
You're at a Google event.
You're at a fundraiser.
And you're going to start
with war, famine, disease--
all really important topics,
not the best opening line.
So really, talking
about the little things
is how we find out how we
have something in common.
And you heard Cliff say that
I'm also a Fighting Illini.
Here's how it happened.
That picture, I was at an event.
And Jeff Huber, who is
a University of Illinois
grad with Google Labs,
he was our speaker.
And he brought Google Glass for
us to demonstrate and try on.
You'll notice I'm
wearing the orange pair--
because after all, orange
is our Illinois color.
So I decided to send
Cliff that picture.
And I explained to him--
probably in more detail
than he wanted to
know, but it was
significant-- saying why I was
wearing Google Glass, about
Jeff, I went to Illinois.
I got back an email
from Cliff saying,
you aren't going
to believe this.
I went to Illinois, and
I grew up in Champagne.
You never know that little
bit of added detail,
that some people call small
talk, connects us to people.
How many of you have a
favorite sports team?
OK, what is your
Your college football
team, which one is that?
USC Trojans.
OK, I won't say that I was
there and Stanford fan here.
OK, I won't say that.
Anyone else?
Favorite teams?
Yes?
The Calgary Flames,
the hockey team?
Yes, yes.
Now really, did you
know him before?
Would you two please
turn around and look
at each-- we've got two
Calgary Flames teams.
Actually, I know the team
well because my cousin
lived in Calgary and was one
of the TV cameramen there.
This is a little detail.
This is the perfect
example of how
you find something in common.
And I'm going to give
you the roadblock.
The first roadblock, I call
the mother's dire warnings.
The first one is, don't
talk to strangers.
How many of you heard
that growing up?
Don't talk to strangers.
The rest of you who
didn't raise your hand,
your parents didn't love you.
Don't talk to strangers,
that's sensible.
That make sense.
When you're here at this amazing
campus, nobody is a stranger.
We should be able to smile and
just say hello to everyone.
When I was writing
my third book,
I was at Time Warner building.
And one of the
things that happened
was that my editor
said, you know,
we really don't go into
elevators with certain people.
She said everybody
knows the receptionist.
I said, really?
She says, oh yeah.
When you see someone you
don't want to talk to
or you're kind of
afraid of the big boss,
you talk to the receptionist.
The receptionist
knew more people
who worked for Time
Warner because people
were afraid of having a
conversation in an elevator
with someone that they didn't
know-- who, by the way,
might be someone who could
tell them about another job
that they might
be interested in.
So instead of don't
talk to strangers,
here's the remedy--
redefine a stranger.
This is old school.
You're getting a handout.
On the handout, it has
my contact information,
but it also has five
tips and a bonus
that you could share with
other people if you like,
and the link to the
infographic, which
is the step by
step of how to work
a room that's on my website.
But instead of don't talk to
strangers, redefine a stranger.
Everywhere you go,
you should think of,
what do I have in
common with people?
Could be the Calgary Flames.
Anyone here like Chicago
style deep dish pizza?
Would you please
raise your hands?
We're going out afterwards
for deep dish pizza,
or we'll get the
cafeteria to make--
you know, some big arguments
over thin crust and deep dish
pizza.
And some people are going, well,
that's insignificant, silly
conversation.
I'm from Chicago.
When you talk thick,
deep dish pizza,
that's not insignificant.
That's really important.
Some people are laughing
because they know it's true.
The second thing that stops
us is often we will hear,
gee, we should
only talk to people
that we've been
properly introduced to.
Wouldn't you love to have
Cliff go with you everywhere?
And every time you
walk in a room,
he says those grate
things about you?
A few trumpets, we could
have gotten here at Google,
would've been nice
to herald the entry.
But really, we're on our own.
So I want to give
you the remedy.
The remedy is,
everywhere you go,
before you go there-- and let
me ask you, how many of you
belong to other professional
groups off campus?
What do you belong to?
OK, so you belong to ACM, a
professional organization.
I saw a hand over here.
Where do you-- oh, I
actually spoke for Cal CPA.
So Cal CPA, Right it's northern
California society of CPAs.
anyone else?
Generally, we do other things.
Anyone's been to a party lately?
Nobody invites Googlers.
Anyone been to a party?
Yes?
Where was your party?
Moved into a new neighborhood
and the neighbors
invited for barbecue.
It's so good to know that really
this idea of the welcome wagon
and making people feel welcome
and comfortable still exists.
Because look, when we
move into a neighborhood
and that feels good, when
we start a new project that
feels good, feeling welcomed.
And that's what "How to
Work a Room" is about.
It's about making
people feel welcomed,
making people feel important,
and extending ourselves.
That's important.
In fact, watch this.
Oh hi, I'm Susan RoAne.
It's so nice to meet you.
SHANNON: Hi, I'm Shannon Lee.
SUSAN ROANE: And
Shannon Lee-- did
you hear that
enthusiasm in her voice?
You should have seen this
big smile on her face.
That's why I went over to her.
She's going, I'm never sitting
at the edge with someone
with a microphone that can move.
When we go over to
someone and they
have a smile on their face,
that makes it easier to do.
But you'll notice what I did is
I leaned into the conversation.
Doctor David Schwartz in
"The Magic of Thinking Big"
found that leaders
and the people
we consider the big kahunas,
when they meet people, they
lean into the greeting.
And he said what he
found about these people
that we call our leaders
is that by doing that,
they welcome people.
They do something called
they extend themselves
to other people.
And what "How to Work
a Room" is about,
is extending yourself to people.
And I will give
you a difference.
Instead of thinking, what can I
do to make myself comfortable?
Some of you don't
have pens, some of you
have your computers
and smartphones,
and others are going
to memorize this
because the quiz is next week.
Instead of thinking about
making yourself comfortable,
I'm going to give
you a different way
of looking at this.
What can you do to make other
people comfortable with you?
When you try to make other
people comfortable with you,
you are actually
more comfortable
because they open up.
And when they open
up, then you open up
because they're
responding to you.
And what you have
is a conversation.
So lean in to your greetings.
Don't talk to strangers,
redefine a stranger.
Make sure that you know what
you have in common with people
before you go there.
It's so easy.
We get to Google events.
We get to learn about them.
We get to know who's
going to be there.
We can find out about people.
We can go to LinkedIn.
We can go to their websites.
There's almost no reason
to go anywhere not knowing
who's going to be
there, or not knowing
the generic person of
who's going to be there
and what you have
in common with them.
But then there's
that other thing
that stops us, which we
would like that introduction.
And I'm going to give you
three RoAne tips for what
a self introduction is like.
They're a little different
than what you've heard.
In fact, I just sent
a tweet yesterday
that I send out periodically.
Your self introduction
is not an upchucking
of an elevator speech.
A self introduction
is a pleasantry.
It's not 15 or 30 seconds.
You're at an event.
You have a beverage in one
hand and a significant dessert
in the other, which would
mean lots of chocolate.
So what you do is,
instead of thinking, OK,
what am I going to say?
What you do is you do a seven
to nine second introduction.
It's a pleasantry.
Nobody wants to hear 15 to
20 to 30 seconds about you
or what you do.
It's a pleasantry.
And you heard, it looks
and sounds -- oh hi,
I'm Susan RoAne, it's
so nice to meet you.
And it should look and
sound like it's nice.
This is the one
thing that I've kept
in the book all
iterations for 25 years
because it's so important that
people know that we really
need to feel
comfortable and make
other people
comfortable with us.
Seven to nine seconds.
But how I learned, the
reason why I wrote that is I
was reading this book to edit
it and to change and update it
for this version.
And I went, that's why
I've been telling people
seven to nine seconds.
David Gibbons did
research on eye contact.
And he found that
after nine seconds,
it's considered a glare.
Thank goodness I read my book.
Now I can tell you
where that came from.
Seven to nine seconds,
it's a pleasantry.
The second aspect of
your self introduction
anywhere is that it's
linked to the event.
So any time you're
with other Googlers,
you have something that
you're going to link to.
You're at a wedding.
So I had to say
at the wedding, I
don't know if I'm on the bride's
side or the groom's side.
Because really, I could
have said, I'm Susan RoAne.
I'm a fabulous keynote speaker
and a splendidly best selling
author-- all of which were true.
However, at a
wedding, nobody cares.
They want to know, do
you know the bride?
Do you know the groom?
How did you come to be here?
Because you have to
give people context.
And that's what I try
to do in the book--
give everyone context for
whatever event they were at.
So I had to tell them
why I didn't know.
And the reason is,
I knew the bride.
I met the groom.
But in one of those
small talk conversations,
he happened to mention
his uncle's name--
which was different from
his-- and my ears perked up.
And I said, any
relation to Doctor Al?
He goes, oh yeah.
That's my grandfather.
And I said to him,
my dad and your dad
and your grandfather
were dearest friends.
And my mom and dad would
fly out from Chicago
to visit your grandfather
and grandmother.
I didn't know what
side to sit on.
But I embraced both of them.
And why I tell you
this story, it's
always important to give people
a context for why you're there.
They don't know.
What should they
talk to you about?
But if you help them, it's
like the Jerry Maguire line--
"Help me help you." and
give people context.
Another thing that
stops us, and that is we
were told that good things
come to those who wait.
How many of you heard that?
Good things come
to those who wait.
How many of you
are still waiting?
AUDIENCE: For what?
SUSAN ROANE: For
what is the question.
Good, for what.
We wait.
I want to give you
the RoAne version.
It's good things come
to those who initiate.
Good things come to
those who initiate.
Whether you're going
over the person
first, whether you're
picking up the phone
first, whether you're sending
the first email or interoffice
note, good things come
to those who initiate.
Doctor Adele Scheele who
wrote "Skills for Success,"
in an article she wrote for
the original Success magazine
said that instead of acting
like a guest at events,
if you act like the
host, that helps
people be more
comfortable with you.
Anyone know a good host?
OK, no one knows a good host.
Some of you are nodding.
We're going to go
to this one then.
Now we're going to get
you to practice your self
introductions.
And I want you to
think of how you're
going to introduce yourself to
people right here in this area
that you don't know.
I want you to turn around
and look around the room
and looked at
people say, gee, who
have I seen that I really
haven't met and talked to?
Because this is
your opportunity.
You're not going
to get to escape,
because I'm going to
be surrounding you.
But I did say in
"How to Work a Room"
that you can't work
a room on your tush.
So you're going to have a chance
to practice the exact thing
that we wrote about in the
book that you came here
to hear about at the
bargain rate of $5
from Books Inc, a wonderful
independent bookstore,
and for the people Livestreaming
and watching this on YouTube,
please support your local
independent bookstores,
and certainly Books Inc. And if
you want to hear it on audio,
McMillan Audio can
get that for you.
But what you want to do is
you want to meet people.
So I want you to
look around again,
see what you're going to do.
Because I'm going to give
you about 3 and 1/2 minutes.
Don't look at me like that.
This is an assignment.
I'm going to give you
3 and 1/2 minutes,
and you're going to meet
three people that you haven't
met yet right here at Google.
How many of you are sitting next
to someone you already know?
Good thing I'm here.
All right, so think about
seven to nine seconds linked
to this event, which would
be Susan RoAne at Authors
at Google.
And the third part of it is
the benefit of what you do.
I think it was my friend
Patricia Fripp said
that really, RoAne, don't
tell them to give their title.
Give them the benefit.
How you know how
to give a benefit?
When I was writing
"What Do I Say Next?"
I saw a gentleman in the
coffee shop every day.
And one day I said to
him, what do you do?
And he gave me the
perfect benefit state.
And he looked at me
totally deadpan and said,
I help rich people
sleep at night.
So I said to him, really?
You're a pharmacist?
And he wasn't.
He was a financial planner.
But he gave me the benefit.
It allowed me to
ask the question.
Then we were connected.
And because of that, we're
still in communication,
and it's been a while.
So on your mark, get
set, look around.
And the other part is you
can't work a room on your tush,
so rise and schmooze.
Pick your people.
You have 3 and 1/2 minutes.
[CHATTERING]
[WHISTLING]
I couldn't resist
my train whistle
that I actually bought in
the children's department
of the Chicago
Botanical Garden for $3.
And it worked, so there we go.
How many of you
met three people?
Great.
How many of you met
more than three people?
The Googler fast trackers,
thank you very much.
Did you notice that the
noise level was really high
when you met each other?
Did you hear how much
laughing was going on?
You really liked
meeting each other.
How many of you met at least
one person you didn't know?
Great.
And I saw a couple
people exchanging cards.
Did anyone else exchange cards?
OK, really?
This is your lot in life
for the rest of your life.
For those of the people
watching at Livestream,
I hope you met some people
in the room you're in,
and anyone who watches
this on YouTube.
But those of you here,
everywhere you go,
whenever you see
a crowd, you are
destined to hear me on
your left shoulder going,
go over and talk to them.
Make them feel comfortable.
You are officially
cursed-- but in a good way.
So the people who were
approached by other people,
would you raise your hand?
Tell me, how did it
feel to be approached?
It feels welcoming.
Not you guess, you were right.
That was the right answer.
It feels welcoming.
What else?
How else did it feel when people
came over and talked to you?
Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: Flattered.
SUSAN ROANE: Oh, flattered.
Thank you.
Welcoming and flattered.
You know what,
anywhere we go where
we feel welcomed is special.
But when you go over to
someone, what you're saying
and why it makes
you feel flattered
is it's as if you're saying,
you look like someone
I ought to meet.
You look important.
You look smart.
You look like you have great
ideas I need to know about.
It's flattering.
I doubt that anyone
walks into a room
for any reason with the purpose
of standing alone and no
one talking to them.
I have spoken to CEOs.
I've spoken to actually
political lobbyists.
I've spoken to a variety
of groups of people.
And I can tell you, nobody
walks in a room to stand alone.
Because I don't care how their
celebrity is, what a big kahuna
they are.
When someone is standing
by themself in the room,
their internal voice
is saying, oh my gosh.
I'm alone.
I must be a dork.
That's what we all think.
So when you go over to
someone, it's welcoming.
It's acknowledging.
It's flattering.
And you heard it here.
That's what people said.
Now, those of you who were
the mingling mavens-- a term
I trademarked, but I'll
share that with you.
The mingling mavens,
would you raise your hand,
the people who went
over to other people?
Can you tell me what
they did that made it--
besides that I told you
you had to-- but could
you tell me what they did that
made it OK to go over to them?
Smiled.
They smiled.
People, if you have pen
or pencil or your laptops
or your tablets with
you, write that down.
This is scientific genius.
They smiled.
And what else did they do that
made it OK to go over to them?
Eye contact.
Of course, let's just say
someone sees a piece of lint
on their clothes.
Do you go over them and go,
it is so nice to meet you?
No.
The eye contact, when
you're looking at people,
they assume you're
interested in meeting them.
That smile and eye
contact are welcoming.
They allow people
to feel engaged.
So if you take
away nothing else,
smile and give eye contact
in every room you're in.
And I understand there are
some things that are cultural.
Different cultures
have different thoughts
about smiling and eye--
well, not about smiling,
but certainly about eye contact.
But I'd like you to
embrace that for here.
"How to Work a Room" has been
published in 13 countries.
It's been a best seller in
Taiwan and China and Mongolia
and in Croatia.
I can't figure that one out yet.
But it's cross cultural.
People want to know in other
countries, how do I fit in?
How do I make myself
comfortable at events?
I don't proclaim to have
every international etiquette.
You can get that
by going to Google
and finding out what
country you're at
and what those protocols are.
But you just did this.
You actually met people.
Did people make it easy
for you to talk to them?
Did anyone have an
interesting conversation
that they'd like
to share with us?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SUSAN ROANE: How
interesting, that there
are new jobs and organizations
because things have changed,
a piece that you
might not have known
had you not talked to her.
There are new titles.
Things do change.
I'm not really good
about a lot of change.
But I'll tell you, I've
celebrated an anniversary--
I believe it was last month--
seven years with my own YouTube
channel.
Seven years.
And then I went
back and I looked
at some of the things that
were there seven years ago.
And I thought, I
remember when my hair
was that color naturally.
It's kind of interesting.
Things have changed.
In a million years
did I ever think
that I would've embraced social
media and been a Twitterer.
In two months, I
celebrate-- I believe
it's my six year
anniversary with Twitter.
You must be thinking, boy, she
doesn't have much of a life.
Her anniversaries are
with social media.
But the reality is,
I've been tweeting.
I went and counted how
many tweets one day.
The other two days ago,
I hit my 7,000th tweet.
And you know what my tweet was?
"Now I know where
all that time went."
But I love it.
I did a tweet here.
Whoever thought the
tidbits-- and I've
learned so many
things from Twitter.
Here's another thing
about social media.
I have a very good friend
I met because of a tweet.
And I wrote that in the book.
I wrote our story.
She put up-- no, Daniel
Pink retweeted her tweet
saying that his new
book was superb.
So I retweeted it.
Next thing I know, I
don't hear from Dan,
but I hear from Dori Clark,
who wrote "Reinventing You."
Thanks for retweeting my tweet.
I saw that she was
writing a book,
and she wrote for
"Forbes" I wrote her back.
She wrote me back.
I said, when your
book comes out,
let me know what I
can do to support it.
We considered
ourselves such friends
that when I wrote
the book in June,
we had never even
had a conversation.
But because of Twitter
and then email,
we thought we were friends.
Well, I've met her twice.
And I'm delighted to
say we are friends.
Because next Thursday,
going out to dinner with her
when she comes here.
It's great to have social media.
It's great to have email.
But there is nothing
like what you just
did with face to face to
build the conversation
and build the connection.
I'm going to stop and ask
you, what questions do
you have for me
that I can answer
that will make you
go away saying, boy,
was that worth an
hour of my time?
AUDIENCE: You see someone
a lot, a few times,
and you always want
to talk to the person.
But after a while, and you
haven't talked to that person.
You're kind of shy to approach.
So what do you do
in that situation?
SUSAN ROANE: What you do.
I think, doesn't that
happen to a lot of us?
You keep it so
nobody says anything.
Let's take the hint from
Doctor Adele Scheele
and say, initiate.
Don't wait.
Be that good host
that she talked about.
Here's what you do.
The next time you see the
person, just say, you know?
I just heard Susan RoAne talk
at one of our wonderful Google
benefits.
She said I should talk to you.
I've seen you.
You look interesting.
Say something.
Blame me.
Susan RoAne made me do it.
But don't wait.
You have a great smile.
You're so approachable
and easy to respond to.
Say something.
Because look, you're
asking me this.
That means that you regret
that you haven't said anything.
No regrets.
Here's the worst thing
that could happen.
The person's going--
because they're shy.
But give them a second chance.
Because you know,
we think people
back off because
they're not interested.
It could be their mind is
on a project they're doing.
Or maybe they have to move
and they're thinking about,
do I have to go to Craigslist
and look for an apartment?
So you promise me.
My email us on the
handout that you
have in the back of the book
which you're going to buy.
Would you please
send me an email?
Yeah, you know, I mean, it's
supporting a local bookstore.
Would you please
email me and let
me know what the response was?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
SUSAN ROANE: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My question is, how do you
break into a conversation that's
already ongoing when
you walk into a room?
SUSAN ROANE: How many
of you had that happen?
You walk in a room and
everyone's in groups,
and you want to walk out?
All of us.
Here's what you do.
In this section in
"How to Work a Room,"
I've kept this section.
I call it breaking and entering.
So here's what you do.
You see, you walk into the room.
Hint from shy people--
the research, and this
is social science research--
shy people almost never make
a grand entrance.
They usually come to
an event no later than
15 minutes after it's
called, because they don't
want to see everyone in a group.
So that's what
your new mantra is.
Get there on time, or only
15 minutes after it's called.
Look around the room.
Pick the group that's
having the best time.
Why?
Because they'll be
easier to walk into.
Pick the upbeat group of at
least three but four people.
Because you can be
sure four people
aren't having an
intimate conversation.
And if they are,
that's the group
I'd like to be talking to,
because that would be fun.
But what you do is you
stand in the periphery.
And when someone looks your
way, you say something just
about the conversation
they're having.
It's not the time to
change to your subject.
And then you can step in and
continue the conversation.
But I had someone
who was from Toronto.
And my mother was from
Toronto, and she just
thought Canadians are so much
more polite than we were.
And then this woman said this
in my seminar in New York,
and I thought it was genius.
She said to me-- she always
had a big smile on her face.
She'd go to a room, pick that
group that was having the most
fun, and she'd stand
on the periphery.
And when someone would look
her way, what she did is,
she said-- big smile-- do
you mind if I join you?
What a brilliant idea.
She said nobody ever said, "No,
as a matter of fact, we do."
No one ever said that.
And then she was part
of the conversation.
But I'm going to make
this my Google get,
so here's what you do.
When you're at any
event-- social, business--
and you see someone with your
peripheral vision, which we all
have, that you know wants
to get in the group,
you be the mingling
maven, that great host.
Take one step back.
Because when you
take a step back,
you will have included the
person who's been excluded.
There's no reason to talk
about diversity and inclusion
if we don't step back
and include people.
Would people remember
the person that
makes them feel welcome
and comfortable?
I think so.
So that would be how to get in.
Does that make sense?
Does that help?
And we have another question.
AUDIENCE: And since
you mentioned Croatia,
how do you approach somebody
who's from another culture?
Should you assume that you
know about his culture,
if you know a few bits about it?
Or should you approach
him with a blank slate,
like completely trying
to be completely open?
SUSAN ROANE: You shouldn't
do what I just did.
But here's the one thing.
If you know a little
something about the culture
that you can make the
person more comfortable,
I say go ahead and
observe whatever
those cultural norms are.
But most people are forgiving.
I think if you show
interest and you're friendly
and you're open,
people don't assume
that you know everything
about their culture.
And how about this, here's a
great way to find out, is say,
I just wanted to meet you.
I didn't want to do anything
that was inappropriate.
I hope I haven't.
And ask them.
People will tell you, they're
happy to espouse that.
But I think the fact
that you approach people,
don't let that stop you.
Right in this room, we have
people from different cultures.
And you were all
talking up a storm.
Nothing stopped you from
talking to other people
in our little exercise, did it?
So keep on doing that.
I always figure,
if we ask people,
that's the way we learn
about people's cultures is
we find out by asking.
Does that makes sense to you?
Anyone else?
Oh yes, my new friend.
OK.
AUDIENCE: In one situation, I
was sitting in a shuttle bus
and trying to have a
conversation with somebody
that I don't know.
But he works in the same
company but had no interest
in having a
conversation with me.
[LAUGHTER]
And in fact, one time
he offered carpooling
to go back to the
shuttle bus station.
So we were sitting together
for about half an hour.
And I kept on asking
him questions.
He never asked me a
single question back.
So in a situation like this,
how could you overcome?
SUSAN ROANE: OK.
A couple of things.
Number one, that person might
really be completely shy.
That's one thing.
But I'm now going to put on
my judgmental hat and say,
and maybe that person
had no confidence,
but maybe that person was so
focused on what they're doing
that they really didn't--
they shut out people.
There are people that say
that they're introverts so
that they really don't
want to talk to people.
I think when someone is
not interested at all,
they say that on an airplane.
There's some of us like to
talk and some of us don't.
Believe it or not, I'm one of
the people that don't talk.
And there's a reason.
The speech therapist
says those of us
who speak for a living shouldn't
gulp in all that recycled air.
It harms your vocal cords.
With that person, I
would try someone else.
That's where-- by the way,
when you're talking to someone
and they're not interested
and you give it two and three
times, there are 100 other
people that are nice.
I won't even say what I
would have said in Chicago,
other than we had
a really big lake,
and we bought
people cement shoes.
Just as a thought.
I think you've done everything.
You have a great smile.
But after that, go
to the next person.
AUDIENCE: Question is
a little bit different.
How do you manage knowing a lot
of people and staying in touch?
Because I tend to meet
people from everywhere,
all over the world.
I live in so many
different places.
And I generally like
a lot of those people.
But it gets sometimes
so difficult,
and I feel like I'm having
an Alzheimer's and I'm
forgetting people's
names and faces.
SUSAN ROANE: As long as
you don't forget your own,
you're OK.
I think that that happens.
This is why it's
beautiful that we
could have LinkedIn and
Facebook, et cetera,
because we can stay
in touch with people--
a little touch, a little
poke, a little tweet.
But it really is about
staying in touch.
And here's the other thing--
it's an investment of time.
And it doesn't mean you stay in
touch with everyone every day,
but a little note
that just lets people
know you're thinking of them.
And that's when we
know a lot of people
and we have this huge
network and we like people.
I would say, I'd
invest that time--
and you could be
multitasking and doing
something else at
the same time--
to stay in touch with people
you really know and like.
Because in the long
haul, what you develop
is a network of really
great people in your life
that you can count on
and who can count on you.
I think this is where
social networking is
a wonderful opportunity
of staying in touch.
You know what I do?
And I don't even remember
who I gave my phone to.
When I go back and look
at my pictures-- oh,
he put it in his pocket.
Wait till he finds out that the
case is from Claire's and it's
bejeweled.
It's going to be
very interesting.
You know what I do?
I go back to the photos.
And I'll see a photo I took
with someone or of someone.
And I'll just quickly text
it to them or email and say,
I saw this photo.
Was thinking of the
wonderful memory.
And it's just a wonderful way
to stay in touch with people.
But I'm going to give
you the hint from secrets
of savvy networking-- one by
you-- you can work a room.
You can engage.
You can connect.
But if you don't follow up
and stay in touch with people,
you don't have that network
of friends that you need.
Because the followup
is essential.
The best traits of
savvy networkers,
they follow up when they say
they're going to follow up
and do what they say
they're going to do.
You can invite
people on LinkedIn.
You can invite them on
whatever Google company board
that you have.
But stay in touch with people.
Don't wait for them.
Remember what I said, initiate.
Be the person that
extends yourself.
Because what do you want?
Don't you all want
a network of people
that help you grow as you
move forward in your careers?
That's how you get them.
And then sometimes they'll
even cook you a meal.
AUDIENCE: I think a lot of
times what's holding me back
from the initiating a
conversation is I'm not sure
if I can end it smoothly.
As a matter of fact,
I think it's easier
to start a conversation
than to end it.
Do you have tricks?
SUSAN ROANE: You
are on the money.
I'm going to give you one
of my books as a present.
That is the number one question
I've been asked, not 25 years,
30 years that I've been
talking about this.
And what he said
is, how do you end?
And a lot of people don't start
because they don't want to end,
because we don't want to
hurt people's feelings
and we want a gracious
ending, right?
Three ways to end conversations.
It's also on my
website on my blog.
But three ways to end
conversations-- and it's
in the book.
First way, when you've
had a great conversation
with someone, oh, it's
so nice to talk to you
about the 49ers and
their draft picks.
I just made that up, but that
is what I've been talking about.
Now notice.
Shook hands, I didn't
necessarily lean in,
but it was so nice to
talk to you about it.
And then I summarized
a little phrase
so he knows I was
listening and that I
was part of that conversation.
So nice to talk to you about.
And then what you
do is, if you want
their card-- do we
still give out cards?
I saw them at Google.
I had one guy on a plane said to
me, oh, I take people's cards,
take a picture,
and throw them out.
Well, that makes me feel good.
You could have not told me that.
But exchange cards.
And what if you
want someone's card?
Oh, do you have a card?
Now, I once asked that to a
gentleman who looked at me--
I tell you-- totally
deadpan and said, yes.
OK, could I have one?
About 20 years later,
I said, tell me.
Why did you just say yes
and not give me a card?
Here was his answer--
you hadn't asked for one.
Don't play card games.
It's silly.
That's a waste of time.
So ask for someone's card.
And then what if they
don't ask for yours?
What you could say-- and this is
completely contrarian to those
who want to get to the
point-- don't save time.
Say, may I offer
you one of mine?
May I please offer
Well, why don't I
just give them a card?
Because there's something about
the manners and the etiquette
and showing that
you have manners
that's really memorable.
OK, then here's what I would do.
I would then walk a quarter of
the room away to someone else.
(WHISPERING) Here's my book.
No, to someone else
who is standing alone,
because I know he doesn't
want to be standing alone,
or to another group of people.
But walking a quarter
of the room away
is really important, because
that way you don't make someone
feel you've just turned
your back on them.
That's where that
expression comes from.
Does that make sense?
Another way that you
exit-- and by the way,
that gives you the card.
Then you can follow up later
and invite them to LinkedIn
and connect and send an email.
I know that sounds antiquated,
but once in awhile,
I even do that.
And how about this?
Sometimes if you
had a conversation
that you really want to
continue and you've both
talked about
continuing it, here's
a really interesting thought.
You can take out your
phones, get that phone app,
and call them.
That will really show
how different you are.
You pick up the phone.
And by the way, those of you
who have the book, somewhere
in the book-- and
I can't remember
where-- there is a
QR code and a URL.
But if you run your phone
over it or you plug in the URL
to your browser, you get a
special, online-only extra
chapter that has to
do with the phone.
And I wish I could
tell you which page,
but I don't remember.
Talk about not
remembering things.
Oh, there's one on the back.
That leads to a video.
But the one inside leads to
a special online chapter.
Thank you, he pointed out
what I should have said.
I tried to make this book
in 25 years interactive.
So on the back,
there's a QR code.
And when you run your
phone over it, what it does
is up pops a video
of me saying what's
different and new in the book.
So did that help
you, how to exit?
Let's just say-- let me
give you another exit.
Let's say you had a
conversation with someone
and it wasn't going anywhere.
Here's what you do.
Don't say, I've had a
great time talking to you,
because it hasn't
been a great time.
It's been like pulling
teeth, a little root canal.
So what you say to them is-- and
don't any of you say this to me
later-- I hope you enjoy
the rest of the event.
Big smile.
And you still walk a
quarter of the room
away, because that person might
be thinking about something
else that happened at home,
and they're not responsive
because they're distracted.
But the next time you see
them, it might be wonderful.
And then the third
one isn't really
moving away from someone.
The third one is, oh, I see Joe.
Have you met him?
Why don't you come on over?
It's called the bring along.
And then you're in a
group conversation.
So you have three ways to exit.
Well, one question
I'm often asked
is, what do I do
if I forgot a name?
Have any of you
encountered that?
OK, here's what you do.
I know that there are name
and memory specialists that
will tell you, much
like Doctor Seuss,
to put a cat in a vat
in a hat on their head.
But what I would say is, when
you forgot someone's name
and you know their face is
familiar, save some time
and go over and say, it's
just been one of those days.
I know your face.
I know we've met.
Could you help me out and
remind me of your name?
It's direct.
Now here's what happens.
Every person has
forgotten someone's name.
If it's your sister or your
mother-in-law, not so cool.
But people have
forgotten people's names.
And then they'll tell you
stories how they forgot a name.
But if you say that
up front, that works.
But here's another technique.
And I learned this
from a gentleman
who was the vice president
of the Harlem Globetrotters.
Well, I knew he was the vice
president in the main office
because he was 5'5.
But he told me this.
He said-- and I kept this in
the book 25 years-- he said,
Susan, what you tell people
is when they go somewhere
and they see someone that
they recognize but they really
don't remember a name,
he said, always-- even
if you've seen that
person five times--
always put your hand
out and say your name.
Hi, I'm Susan RoAne.
VINCE: Vince Lacey.
SUSAN ROANE: Yes.
He's just looking at me
smiling, going, oh my God.
I'm not safe from her.
OK, here's what Manny said.
When you go over
and say your name,
you can bet if you didn't
remember their name after six
months, they have no
clue of your name either.
But when you see your
name, 90% of the time,
people will respond in kind.
Then you both know
each other and reminded
each other of your names.
And then you're
having a conversation.
Does that help you
around remembering names?
And then just tell the truth.
I'm going to have
any more questions,
and then I'm going to close.
Any more?
Who has the microphone?
Oh, you do.
Any questions, Cliff?
CLIFF: I think we're set
a questions for now, so.
SUSAN ROANE: OK.
Working a room is work.
I've had people say-- and
I'm going to stay here
so that I sign the book.
I once was signing a book,
and I was writing a sentence.
And the guy looked at
me and say, really?
You write a whole
lot for an autograph.
Because I don't
just sign my name.
And I said, really,
the autograph was easy.
Writing the book, really
hard, but well worth it.
Because I know it's served
people over a number of years
and continues to serve
people, because I want you all
to be able to walk into any
room and have a good time
and meet who you want to meet.
And by the way, when you're
wearing anything from Google--
I saw the Google girl power and
I've seen some Google shirts--
it starts conversations.
I have a shirt that
says, "Give me chocolate,
and nobody will get hurt."
It starts conversations.
I'm good to end with something
that actually happened.
When "How to Work a
Room" first came out,
I spoke for the
Commonwealth Club.
It was absolutely an honor
for me, a former teacher.
Two men were in the second row.
But I went before the talk.
I held the book, my
baby, under my arm
and I-- what brought you here?
It was so nice to see
you, thank you for coming.
And then one of them looked at
me with the face, and he says,
I just have a
question to ask you.
This is before the talk.
I knew it wasn't going
to be a good one.
He said, how did you
take a 200 page book
and think you're going
to give a 45 minute talk?
Well, there's
something about humor--
and I wrote about in the
book-- that I channeled
my grandfather, who was known as
having a great sense of humor.
And I was so lucky the
answer came to me then
that might have happened an
hour later while I hit my head.
And I looked at the guy.
And I said, the only way you
can handle someone that's
sounding so negative
is with humor.
And I said to him, you
think that was tough?
I took a 45 minute talk and
turned it into a 200 page book.
And now you have the
300 page version.
And it's the silver anniversary.
And I am so delighted
to be here at Google.
I can't thank Cliff enough.
We now have a whole
new room of-- I've
anointed you the
mingling mavens.
You have my email.
Any questions that come up
that I haven't answered,
feel free to let me know.
And I promise you an answer.
So thank you very much, and
I hope you'll tell every one.
And I'm available, and I'll
keep on Googling, you guys.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.